el ataque ocurrió a plena luz del día
hacia las 2 y 40 de la tarde -hora
local- de oakland en nueva zelanda este
hombre de nacionalidad de sir lanka
llegó al supermercado sacó un cuchillo y
atacó a las personas inocentes que
estaban allí haciendo sus compras la
policía reaccionó y logra batirlo en
menos de un minuto de inmediato la
primera ministra de nueva zelanda ya sin
darder convocó a una conferencia de
prensa y fue enfática al decir que se
trató de un ataque terrorista de tipo
individual que nada tiene que ver con
religión con culturas o con etnias esto
por supuesto para evitar cualquier
expresión de xenofobia en nueva zelanda
también dijo que este hombre había
llegado al país hace 10 años y que desde
hace cinco años era seguido de cerca por
parte de la policía pues había
informaciones de que era simpatizante
del autodenominado estado islámico y
también sería sospecha de que estaba
planeando un atentado de este tipo
incluso estuvo bajo arresto pero fue
dejado en libertad por falta de
evidencia también hay una orden de la
corte que les impide a las autoridades
revelar por ahora su identidad pero ya
se está solicitando a la corte que
retire esta medida para qué zelanda le
pueda contar al mundo la identidad de
este atacante